hello and welcome to this video versus
crypto chess this is a five-minute game
crypto chess i only have played two
games against surprising feels like
there were more so this some handler
that i'm kind of have on the on the map
as i have played them before um okay so
i've got the banco with these six here
yeah i can try this I mean I often
comply Quincy to in this kind of
position but night pd2 is also possible
preparing e-form ya hear a b3 is
interesting I don't know be three year
gam try this is a bit of a creative
approach just not taking the porn and
trying to oppose this Bishop there
sometimes black players go for a five
here but I think I'm probably taking
this
now you couldn't go a five so
hmm I'm a bit surprised that he took
their 96 I was more was more on my list
of expected moves that same um how to do
this specially to our Bishop d3 probably
to Bishop d3 might be in some kind of
tempo with 94 95 so
yeah blacks a pawn is cause for concern
I wonder if I should have played some
moves like Quincy to may be covering be
too so that I have things like that Seyi
5d is 6ft 65 if I do that now he has
some 94 for example using the
unprotected State of the bishop okay is
taking a long time if I've is a typical
strategy in this kind of position for
black switching back to a king side play
no place east 6 mm well as I said taking
I didn't didn't like so much but
yeah I don't know honestly if five is
any good fam in the first place okay now
he opens this hmm yeah it's not clear I
can also take with a cheap on giving me
a good square on c4 it's a little bit
more dynamic than taking with the e porn
which doesn't feel bad but
an unprotected State of my bishop on b2
is kind of making me nervous that some
kind of an alumni T for some discovery
could happen
hmm yeah not quite clear what is
supposed to do here it doesn't feel like
a good benoni here the a pawn this week
and c4 is a good square for my night ok
yeah I wondered about Queen a one that
sir an attractive looping move looking
at the a7 porn and yeah making quite
some pressure on that long diagonal so
that black cannot easily play around 95
for example or I even move the f 69 I
think I can go to we can go to h5 but
I'm happy to trade yeah I think I'm
happy to try it and I can take 87
actually is there any reason not to take
the porn I don't see any let's take it
now its strong medicine
telnet savona looks normal g4 back to d2
let's I'm threatening queen to c7 just
attacking districts what is the point
Queen to d4 maybe that could be the
point yeah yeah it's possibly some
counter-plan probably not enough I'm
thinking about Queen a1 just very
brutally taking away any kind of play
now i think i think i should do that
playing something else is just too meek
okay I can't play 96 in here right
noise them any drawback I don't see it i
think i can take it the eight is hanging
NCAA for that matter but the main line
is 93 98 98 Queen c8 and over
no no no moves
now that opening result was was too bad
for black not quite sure what when it
started to become become very bad okay I
can take the ATM but the bishop doesn't
have squares anyway so maybe just move
the move my e2 bishop yeah just keep it
ok I have to be a little bit I have to
be a little bit so time all right here
so that I'm not stumbling into a tactic
with Knight f3 my queen is unprotected
so night c 8 there is night f3 now
definitely 98 is no problem so I think I
can do this though and now Bishop Jake's
is that easier maybe 98 I can take and
yam f5 ok
okay i think i think i'll take care III
I can grab so only issues check the time
I can get back to see eight but the
pawns here I put too much check check
check come on buddy black you really try
everything they are being super quick at
the end how many moves did you play in
the star it's amazing Wow okay so I'm
not not really sure when this opening
I'm turned out so badly from it really
shouldn't I'm playing a non theoretical
thing against the banker with nothing
that should give me much before I mean
of course black can take on c4 but
anyway that shouldn't be a big deal I'm
yeah okay well the computer wants to
just keep things and play here it's
interesting i mean if i take i'm also
giving him ideas here with 95 I'm not
sure that I want that maybe this is
better than just taking here i have a
wind a pond is slightly somewhat we care
okay I was I was also expecting this to
happen the night him but he also didn't
do that
Jim no oh i blundered Knight takes e4
yeah he can play it finally because
there's no rook anymore he ate oops that
would have been embarrassing so I'm that
means i have to improve here because
we're here if I cannot play Bishop d3 if
things are not it not good the computer
wants to do this which is plain terrible
strategically I don't really want to
give up my strong looking bishop now you
could have taken that that's a big miss
ya after that I'm also just worse
clearly worse maybe maybe it's still
somewhat playable but thing is my
remaining pieces are a decently active
the night here the rook is putting
pressure this is weak here and so on so
no this is it's not that bad the
computer gives us all over that's almost
equal but this was not planned of course
i blundered the pawn yeah but after this
i think is he's in bad shape now the
Angelus is very drastic here 1.2 and the
energy i'm just reading up on Queens 796
dear Bishop b5 is also move but I think
this is good enough
check okay f takes is actually also
winning the house as the bishop is
taking the rook yeah okay with the
endgame is good enough okay well thanks
for watching